what was the principal the the inception
of the story where did this character
come to you what were you up to and how
did II materialized in your imagination
what I was up to when I thought of it
was I was still shooting it's
complicated and I was shooting in
Brooklyn with Meryl Streep and steve
martin and alec baldwin and I don't know
whether it was that we're all kind of
the same age that I was thinking about
us or I don't you don't know where ideas
come from it's too hard to even
articulate you know but the idea of an
older man going to work as an intern
just sort of made me giggle but I didn't
make that the movie you know there's
very little about heat that he's an
older man being an intern it really
becomes you know just a friendship i
felt i had written a lot of love stories
i never wanted this one to be a love
story because at first i think well
where would he go to work anyway
obviously a start-up because i want to
put him in the most foreign plays I
don't want him to be but then I like
that you know i did make it the place he
had lived I mean rather worked in all
those years to kind of brought it around
for him and then it's a woman but it
never I never thought about them being
in a romantic relationship well there's
a scene where where they're in a hotel
bed in San Francisco and again I guess
any other film would have gone to that
place and I think that's an incredible
choice that they are not going to do
that that is not this movie well I don't
know if at that point in this movie
anybody I mean let's say something
happen to him like you know I died at
that point I don't think somebody else
would have come in and had them start
kissing at that point in this movie
that's our movie you know he wouldn't
even come in when she says come look at
my room you know he stands when he goes
I see it he would not cross the
threshold and he has one foot on the
floor too he does um I'm going to talk a
little bit more about Jules Jules is
somebody who is incredibly successful
she's not an employee she's the boss was
that also critical to you in this story
yes yes because it's a new kind of
character for me to write to that's an
entrepreneur started around business
started in her dying
with a few people tried on all the
clothes herself you know she just
started with a one-woman operation and
that is that's what you can happen out
20 years ago that couldn't happen you
can't start a business like that you
can't hit your five-year goal in nine
months but you can now because the
Internet is a store that's open 24 7 so
you know it's endless possibilities and
when I did on my research for the movie
and I went to visit different websites i
went to these massive places and i was
like oh there's so many people and they
said yeah we're taking over the next
floor on the next floor it's you know
obviously a blooming business well i
think i think there's a line that she's
met her five-year goal in nine months is
that right so she is very good at what
she does she's very good at what she
does but um you know I sort of equated
it to what you wrote the script are you
really the person to direct it or should
we bring in somebody that maybe knows
how to talk that language you know so
that's what I would tell aunty half the
way you know to me it's something then
that wasn't said to me but I think that
discs I think we all know there's great
writer directors but there are directors
that know a lot more than me about
directing but they don't assign know a
lot more about directing my movies and
that's how she feels about her business
i speaking of your movies I think it was
28 years ago that you did a wrote a
movie called baby boom and I'm curious
if you see a lot of people love that
movie thank you I wonder if it's a
Charles Shire I was possible to see that
movie has some sort of companion piece
to this in terms of what's changed in
those 28 years yes that definitely
occurred to me not well but I was
writing it but while I was making it and
I was saying down hathaway one day you
know I think in some way this is very
interesting for me to have made that
movie in my 30s make this movie in my
60s and she said what can I tell you
something about that movie my mother
went into labor with me while watching
that movie I said well you're not even
that old she said no it was on TV so
somehow had some secondhand shop she
found a baby boom poster and she hung it
in her trailer and headed up the entire
time we were making the movie so she
felt it and I felt it and I think she
feels that her characters sort of stood
on the shoulders of that character and
what is this movie do you think have to
say about balance and we obviously end
the film with a story about balance
about trying to get balance is it to you
a work-life balance is it a personal
balance that's your thinking of the
balances that you're trying to
communicate in this film what are you
thinking about it before you even start
directing as you're writing the film um
both so many things really but and I've
tried Tai Chi and I find I don't know
how many of you tried it it's the best
thing you can do for yourself they
should get older it's quite hard it
looks simple but it's quite hard and it
it's it is about your balance I mean
literally about balance but it's also
you know it's not a literal balance also
a figurative balance and what I think
that's what she needs is to balance
things and just kind of glass line is
breathe deeply Jules just but it's all
going to be okay it's all going to be
okay and I think when you're in the
crunch the way she is you don't know
that it's going to be okay and I think
that's what he's that's what he's doing
for her in the movie you know it is it's
not a romance but I I do consider it a
bit of a love story and he you know I
set my thesis out in the beginning the
first line is you know Freud said life
is I forget the exact words but life is
two things you know love and work so I
start him without love and without work
and then I give him both hmm what were
the conversations that you had with
Robert De Niro and Anne Hathaway about
the characters and what were the
important things to them in terms of
what they wanted to bring to Ben and
jewels and how did you incorporate their
ideas into the performance well Bob's
are pretty sure some of you have worked
with him he's pretty quiet guy he's very
much wants to hear what you want wants
to give you that yeah he's not trying to
turn that neither one of these actors
are the type that want to make it their
own which is good for me because I spent
a long time on the script and it took a
while to get it going and I was
confident in the script so I didn't
really want to reinvent too much but I
mentioned to you out
I I probably had more wardrobe fittings
with Bob and I have with any other actor
and into me and I'm part of this it
looks like he's in the same suit and
everything but but he's you know you
learn a lot about actors from wardrobe
fittings because it's the first time you
get to really hang out with them just
the two of you and you know I could just
see I could see the way he stood in
front of the mirror I saw him becoming
been the only i would say were the only
argument it was hardly an argument was
that I wanted button-down shirts cuz my
dad wore them the button down collar and
he wanted more like a collar you have a
spread collar so we tested both and we
sat in the screening room he was sitting
right here and after we saw him in both
I look like me just said it looks
straighter it looked a little less hip
and we like that it's a more
conservative look and who came up with
the business where he buttons his jacket
whenever he stands and he stands
whenever a woman walks up to him I wide
written that he stands all the time and
Bob did that on his own what about Annie
and her costume that ain't if you're
learning a lot about character through
cost and what about with Annie yeah um
she started out wanting a little bit
more of a funkier look than I did and
then when we sort of hit on a kind of a
modern-day Katharine Hepburn mm-hmm then
she sort of let some of that go but
she's also another wonderful she's a
wonderful person besides being so
enormously talented and again they
wanted to be in this movie the way I
wanted it to be you know they weren't
there to rock the boat you said i think
is why it feels I don't know if you felt
this but I mean I feel that there's like
a smoothness in an East to the movie and
you can feel everybody's going in the
same direction you said this was not an
easy movie to get made hardly it does
that I mean on the spectrum of hard
movies get made where it is part why is
that when what do people tell you when
they didn't want to make it well you
know you know you know well that's an
interesting question but they don't
really tell you that you just know
they're not making it i would i would
get very close i would get I would have
they read it they like it I would go in
I'd meet
we'd actually get a budget somebody even
gave me some notes which work can you
make it shorter so it'll be cheaper then
it doesn't then it goes then it's yeah
yeah yeah great we love it and then it
doesn't happen at the last minute that
happened at a couple places and finally
I was going to do it independently which
made me nervous because I've may have
been making studio movies for 30-some
years but I was going to do it and
things changed at Warner's it was a
different group of people there and they
were one of the companies that had gone
kind of far with me on it so I said
let's try one more time let's send it
back mm-hmm and then you know they said
they were gonna do it I was so thrilled
because I loved making the movie there
well but it's so rare but it was gonna
bury the script in my backyard if that
way before that last Warner's thing
didn't happen I have no idea how to like
work a shovel but I was gonna go to the
hardware store and buy a shovel and
figure it out I was gonna I was invited
all my friends cuz they've been hearing
me talk about it first I'd have like a
wake and actually buried idea I was
gonna buy a box oh my German just put it
in my backyard